um welcome everyone I I want to in a
particular
um welcome our new summer interns
um who
um are here virtually
um and um uh taking part in the summer
internship program and
um I usually kick off the Thursday
conference to give an overview of the
department and the program and and about
the field because probably this field is
somewhat new to you all
um my name is Bill Hirsch I am the chair
of the Department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology
I am also
um uh director of the graduate program
so um so basically as the title says I'm
going to give an overview of the field
the department and some of our
educational programs I do not intend to
talk for the full hour so hopefully
we'll leave some time for uh discussion
and questions
um so who all is here today attending
um mainly the submarine turns you get
top building today there are some new
graduate students in the program who
might be here
there also are some of our fellows from
either one of the other of our
fellowship programs the clinical
informatics Fellowship for Physicians or
the National Library medicine fellows
for
PhD students and postdoctoral students
anyone else who wishes to be here is
welcome to do so but um uh if you've
heard me talk about informatics and
demise I I will not be offended if you
don't stick around for the talk
um because you've heard it all before so
it's up to you
um okay well
um let me then start
um so who who are we
um we we are the department of medical
informatics and clinical epidemiology we
sometimes go by our acronym demise we
can be found at our vanity URL which
redirects to our web page on the OHSU
website we're an academic Department in
the school of medicine so there are
other departments the department of
internal medicine department of surgery
Department of medical molecular genetics
and so forth we are this department and
the main focus of the work we do is in
what people may be more appropriately
called biomedical informatics or
biomedical and health informatics these
days
we're an academic department so the
major focus of our work is research and
education and we also provide various
kinds of leadership and service we do
have some involvement in the
academic in I'm sorry in the operational
side of OHSU in in terms of the health
care delivery system and so forth but
most of that work is done in other
departments and there are cross
appointments and so forth the focus of
demice is more on the academic side of
the field
um so what is this field called
biomedical and health informatics or
biomedical informatics Health
informatics
or the acronym bmhi
and for the summer interns what have you
gotten yourselves into so um I I get
asked this question maybe not as much as
I used to you know in the early days I
got asked my by my parents what are you
going off to learn to study or what do
you work at but anyways um so actually I
have a website that I keep in fact it
has just been I keep it up to date too
it features a bunch of information and a
number of
um
online
um lectures on different topics short
lectures
um that um both kind of introduced the
field and also introduce the technology
that we use for a lot of the teaching
that we do and um this too has a a URL
that that redirects but if you just into
a browser type informatics DOT health
you will get to this website
um I I also keep a Blog and I write
about various things related to the
field including defining what the field
is and back in 2009
um I had the opportunity to write a
paper that defined the field and I
called the field as being concerned with
the optimal use of information often
aided by technology to improve
individual health health care public
health and biomedical research so yes we
work with technology we work with
computers we love working with computers
I have this cool new uh MacBook Pro that
I'm sitting here with that I just got a
week ago
um
but really the focus of what we do in
our work in informatics is to do things
that improve health or Healthcare care
or public health and those sorts of
things that that's the the driver of our
work in fact our professional
association the American medical
informatics Association Amia
describes informatics as the
interdisciplinary field that studies and
pursues effective uses of biomedical
data information and knowledge for
scientific inquiry problem solving and
decision making and then my italics
motivated by efforts to improve human
health so again our at the end of the
day our focus is on improving human
health and Health Care delivery the
accreditation Council for graduate
medical education also defines it
actually defines the field of clinical
informatics I'll try to distinguish with
all these different areas within
informatics are but I I think they have
a good definition too it's the field
that transforms Health Care by analyzing
designing implementing and evaluating
information and communication systems to
again my italics improve patient care
enhance access to care Advance
individual and population Health
outcomes and strengthen the
clinician-patient relationship and you
can find more about these definitions at
the links on this slide which actually
reminds me don't let me forget I I these
there's a PDF of these slides on my
website and I can paste the URL into the
chat when we're finishing up the talk
um some additional perspectives on the
informatics field one comes from the
State University of New York Buffalo
um where there was actually just a
meeting held that some in the department
participated in
um just of this notion that that
informatics is the overlap of people
information and technology
so technology is important but so are
people and information a report in the
early part of this Century from The
Institute of medicine defined the core
competencies for providing
patient-centered care for health
professionals
and one of those important competencies
is utilize informatics some note that
things like search engines are as poor
as important as stethoscopes for the
practice of medicine in the 21st century
another
um kind of perspective it comes from our
colleague Charles Friedman who has
coined the fundamental theorem of
informatics that the goal of informatics
is for the computer to help the human
and make the human do better than he or
she would do without the computer and
the goal is not to replace the human
some people talk about that you know
we're not going to need doctors or
nurses I don't think anyone seriously
believes that certainly not people
working in informatics we want to help
humans do their jobs better
okay so um you hear all these different
words in front of informatics I
sometimes call this the adjective
problem because of the adjective
um of the adjectives that go in front of
informatics but if you look um if you
start at the bottom again informatics is
people plus information plus technology
there are other fields outside of
um biomedicine that use informatics
there's a field of legal informatics
chemoinformatics there's a few others
but the most prominent use of
informatics is in biomedicine and health
and then we span from the cell to the
person to the population so the term
bioinformatics which a lot of people use
sometimes inappropriately because some
people use bioinformatics to refer to
all of this biomedical and health
informatics but bioinformatics is is
more accurately focused on informatics
applied to Cellular and molecular
processes when we move to the person
that's when we get to the level of
clinical or sometimes people use the
word medical that word is kind of fallen
out of fashion and that kind of focuses
on Health Care it also focuses on
consumers consumer health informatics
wearables websites all that stuff and
then also the important area of looking
at the population and we tend to call
that area of informatics Public Health
informatics there are some overarching
areas there's Imaging informatics images
can come from any of these and we can
support research through informatics
from any of these so although there is a
subfield called clinical research
informatics that tends to focus on not
surprisingly clinical research and
supporting it including using data in
things like electronic health records so
um I or other faculty in the department
could give a lecture on each bullet on
this slide that what are some of the
Apple applications probably front and
center is the electronic health record
which is used by physicians nurses and
others to document patient care to keep
a record of their care to manage their
care
and to do other things with it and that
the figure on the right upper right is a
picture from the the system that's used
by the Veterans Administration although
that's being replaced by another system
but but it gives you a nice kind of
overview of the things you see in a
medical record although you can't read
it too well on the slide but things like
notes for patients lab results
appointments Vital Signs consultations
Etc
um another important application is
machine learning and artificial
intelligence those have become very hot
areas with advances in the science
underlying them again we could talk
about that all afternoon
we also search for information I'm sure
probably all of you have done a Google
search but when we are searching for
scientific information we might consult
other sources although you can actually
find some of those same sources through
Google but but the PubMed system of the
National Library medicine is a nice
interface into the
biomedical scientific literature
decision AIDS we we create decision AIDs
that that patients use to help with
shared decision making another important
area is data standards so standardizing
the data so we can move it from one
system to another that that has been a
challenge in the past and also so we can
move on to the next bullet which is
reusing clinical data so carrying out
research
on what's in the clinical data is a very
important area now and and other areas
like Precision or personalized medicine
this notion of being more precise
particularly through the use of genomics
to make decisions about care and and
probably the area of medicine this is
most advanced in is cancer and the
Knight Cancer Institute at OHSU is one
of the leaders in this area and and then
we do evaluation of all of the above
um uh we we not only develop these
applications we evaluate them we see
where they work and where they don't
work how they help people how they
potentially hurt people
in fact
um there are applications in biomedical
and health informatics that fall short
and some of the academic work
in modern times is focused on trying to
make these systems better for example
electronic health records
um probably those of you who are young
cannot imagine the days when you went to
a doctor's office and they opened up a
paper chart and they wrote in it
um and there's all kinds of problems
with paper charts they're illegible they
get lost but as we've discovered there
are also problems with electronic health
records They slow the work of clinicians
down they sometimes prioritize the
non-clinical aspects of care things like
capturing all the activities so the The
Physician or the hospital can generate a
bill which is important for the
economics of their practice but um we
don't necessarily want the electronic
health records to prioritize that and in
fact we see that one of the causes of
burnout among clinicians is the um
adverse impact of the electronic health
record one of the problems that it
really comes down to is that um
clinicians when they um they want to if
you're taking care of a patient you want
to write the story if you have a new
patient coming to you you want to read
the story
um but when we do work with data
um it's much better if the data is
structured and we can use that data for
decision support for research for public
health so there's this tension and and
there are Technologies such as natural
language processing that enable us to
um potentially move between the the
written word and the structured data but
that is a this is a challenge for the
field um I already mentioned about data
standards and internet interoperability
systems that don't talk well to each
other we
um
also having this is certainly not
limited to health care but issues around
privacy and security of our personal
data we want the people who
appropriately should have access to our
data such as those who are providing
Medical Care to us but we don't
necessarily want marketers
um
others to have access to to our data so
so keeping it private and secure so that
it's only used by those who are
appropriately authorized to use it and
then this new challenge we've discovered
as we make more use of data as we use
that data to develop algorithms
oftentimes using machine learning
biases that that either arise because
the underlying data is biased or that
the algorithms are biased or that the
way we apply the algorithms are biased
again you know we could spend the whole
afternoon talking about that topic but I
I just did want to mention it because it
is an important area in our field
so let me then shift gears
um to talk a little bit more about the
department as I already said it's one of
26 departments in the OHSU School of
Medicine our mission is to provide
leadership Discovery I.E research
dissemination of knowledge I.E education
in actually the areas not only of
biomedical informatics but also clinical
epidemiology which is the the second
side of our department they do different
kinds of work equally important and very
successfully
um and then I list the leadership of the
department here myself
um Dr Shannon McQueeney who focuses on
bioinformatics and computational biology
Dr door who focuses on clinical
informatics um Dr Eden who is
um focused on the all-important issue of
Faculty development and and promotion
and Dr Morris who
is mostly focused on in the area of
clinical research and Education and
Training around it
so um we are a national leader um you
can go to U.S news and World Report and
you know who are the leaders at
informatics maybe someday you'll be able
to do that I I don't know that that
would be a good thing but but clearly we
our program is nationally known it's
nationally really internationally known
and recognized
um we are for example one of 18 programs
that are funded by the National Library
of Medicine with the training grant for
a PhD and postdoc students we were among
the first four programs to develop uh
fellowships for the new uh clinical
informatics subspecialty for Physicians
there's now over 50 of these programs we
were among the first
um we are a consistent recipient of
research funding which is obviously
important if you want to do research
um and um our faculty are appointed to
National leadership position
they publish their work in high profile
scientific journals and other venues and
we also have an Ever growing and highly
productive alumni we have over 900
alumni the program dating back to the
first graduates in 1998 and many have
leadership roles heading departments
heading programs working in industry and
government and so forth and the clinical
epidemiology side of the department is
similarly successful in the areas in
which it works which include areas such
as evidence-based medicine the
production of systematic reviews which
are systematic reviews of scientific
topics that bring together all the
research and and the use of tools like
meta-analysis that can combine multiple
studies as if they were a single study
um so a major activity of our department
is our biomedical informatics graduate
program
um you'll you can click on all these
various links when I um give you the PDF
to the slides
um the the overall goal of the program
is to train future professionals
researchers and leaders as we have been
doing in biomedical and health
informatics there are two majors in the
program that focus on different areas
I'll get to that in a second and most
education and informatics is at The
Graduate level so I.E you need a
bachelor's degree to start we are
starting to see some undergraduate
programs develop so bachelor's degrees
in areas like Health informatics but
that's still relatively rare most of the
programs are at the Masters or PhD
levels we have a diverse student body
that fall into you can slice and die ice
them in many ways but we have kind of
first career students who are those who
are just getting started in the field
more likely to be full-time on campus
coming from a variety of backgrounds and
then we have a second group of people
who want to change their careers into
the field of informatics these are
mostly although not exclusively those
from the health care professions
Physicians nurses pharmacists Etc they
tend to already have jobs that they
cancers pick up and leave so they tend
to be part-time students they take
advantage of our distance learning
offerings which we were doing long
before the pandemic
so I mentioned that we have two majors
in the program
um the program was actually really at
the very beginning was called medical
informatics
um it became biomedical informatics but
the the one of the majors We Now call
Health and clinical informatics of
abbreviated hcin this is the original
track of the program and it focuses on
informatics and applied data analytics
in health Healthcare public health and
clinical research settings the
bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine program abbreviated as BCB
tends to be more focused on data science
and related methods that are applied not
only across the various omics genomics
proteomics the microbiome but also
Imaging and the BCB work is beginning to
wend its way into clinical medicine and
public health and I think you'll see
more of that over time
um so the the faculty and Leadership of
the educational program I serve as the
program director I also head up the hcin
area along with Dr Nicole weishkopf Dr
Shannon McQueeney I should actually have
Dr Elise Boudreau here as well on the
BCB
um uh heading up that part of the
program and Dr Eden who oversees the PHD
program and progress of students
that are on our national library
medicine training Grant and and more
importantly we have a a a large number
of Faculty over 30 who teach courses
advise students Mentor them on projects
and so forth and um as commonly happens
in higher education
students identify a faculty Mentor who
with whom they share a common research
interest it's difficult for a student to
pursue a research interest that the
department has no expertise in
um but fortunately with 30 faculty we
cover a wide range in the field
um so we are one of the oldest and
largest programs in the field we have
been doing online education actually
since 1999. we opened the doors of the
Masters program in 1996. we have a lot
of students from actually all over the
world but certainly all over the country
this map is a few years old now but um
lists at one point where all of our
online students live and you see that
they live really across the United
States and in fact internationally as
well we have had many International
students in the department not as much
since the pandemic but
we and we've collaborated on educational
projects with all of these countries
individuals from all these countries
Argentina Singapore the Middle East
Zimbabwe Thailand China and so forth we
have awarded
um actually this uh this the table needs
to be updated with this year's graduates
because we're up to about
940 or so
graduates in our The Graduate
certificate master's degree PhD
and because hcin has been around longer
it's a little bit larger there are more
numbers in in that side
um
our students are highly productive we
don't spend a lot of time in our office
these days but right outside the door to
my office is this bookcase that has some
although not all of the Masters Theses
and
um uh doctoral dissertations and so
forth
so um so we have um we have the full
gamut of graduate degrees we have the
PHD or doctor philosophy typically
pursued by those who want to
um pursue academic careers who want to
do research
um although there are roles for those
who have phds outside of Academia and
Industry Health Care settings and so
forth we have two master's degrees they
really differ only in having the sort of
traditional Masters research thesis or
being more of a professional master's
degree the non-thesis option for those
who are um who aspire to be
practitioners in the field and and
become leaders the research Masters are
often pursued by those who have a
doctoral degree in another field and
then are developing Knowledge and Skills
and informatics we also in the hcin
program have a grad graduate certificate
which is a subset of the master's degree
and and maybe enough knowledge for
individuals to work we as several of our
graduate certificate graduates um have
very successful
um careers and and so forth so that is
another option
um so
um you can look at this Matrix of the
majors I actually that should say majors
in that track there
um and whether they're offered on campus
or online although we've been doing a
lot of things since the pandemic online
including in the other programs but
historically the non-thesis Masters and
graduate certificate of the hcin program
were
um the main online programs but
certainly in the early days of the
pandemic we've gone back to having some
of our in-person classes being in person
again
um but um and and hopefully in the long
run those will all be on campus again
um so the curriculum for each program
um is organized in into courses
um and the courses then are organized
into domains and within each of these
domains our required courses there's
also individual competency where you
select from a list and there are
electives and we call that overall
um uh core collection of courses the
knowledge base and so if you do the
Masters
program you do the knowledge base either
with the thesis or with a Capstone
project in the non-thesis and there is
an option to do an internship if you
want to pursue a PhD you also do the
knowledge base then you do additional
Advanced coursework and of course the
all important research dissertation
um another way to look at this is that
we apply a building block approach and
there have been a number of people who
have
um stepped through these different
programs I mean you can actually enroll
straight into our PhD program
um but um many people have started in
The Graduate certificate and then maybe
moved into the Masters or started in the
Masters and then moved into the PHD and
um again in the in the Master's Degree
you pursue that knowledge base uh The
Graduate certificate has a subset of
that knowledge base and then the PHD has
um
um
additional
courses statistics
um
um the ability to do mentored teaching
and then the all-important dissertation
um another uh way in that paper I wrote
on defining the field I also came up
with this figure just kind of showing
the the diverse inputs into biomedical
and health informatics people come from
Healthcare backgrounds natural and Life
Sciences computer science data science
health information management
um other fields and then you all get
mixed together in the graduate program
and then people come out and and there's
no single career pathway or career
ladder at informatics there's just these
different Pathways in this diagram and
there are some jobs that individuals end
up in that are specific to what they
came in with for example the position of
chief medical information officer is
typically a physician or maybe another
clinician
but a Chief Information officer or
a clinical informatics analyst or
whatever really people come from all
kinds of different um backgrounds so um
but people end up working in Healthcare
Systems in biomedical research
organizations in Industry we've
certainly have plenty of graduates
who've gone into industry or ending up
in in Academia
um another way to look at informatics is
to look at
um the um the work that those who Define
themselves as informatics professionals
do and our professional association the
American medical informatics Association
has
um
uh done this Workforce analysis both for
the health informatics field generally
and then looking also a second analysis
looking more specifically at physicians
in the clinical informatics
sub-specialty although one of the
findings of this analysis was that
there's a substantial amount of overlap
so whether you're you may do different
things as a physician because you bring
different knowledge with you but you do
a lot of the same informatics things and
so there are domains of knowledge
um having fundamental Knowledge and
Skills about
health and health care and informatics
enhancing decision making or if you look
down to domain two under the clinical
informatics of the subspecialty
improving care delivery
um domain three around Information
Systems
um domain four around data and
um interestingly there was another
analysis done back in 2009
where data was in the analysis but it
did not have the prominence that it has
now data is so critically important in
biomedical and health informatics really
in health care and this Workforce
analysis kind of bored that out you can
actually go find these papers on the
Amia website and you can actually see
the the specific tasks and Knowledge and
Skills that are required for these
different areas and then the fifth
domain is around leadership and
profession realism
as in any health profession or really
any profession things like
professionalism are very important
there's a lot of professionalism issues
as we work with data how we interact
with the public with with patients with
other health care providers and so forth
um one other question that you may have
is where does data science fit into all
this there's a nice paper that a few of
our colleagues led by Philip Payne
published a few years back
and um I'm going to go through this
diagram because I I think it is
illustrative so at the at the top and
Center our biological social or
technology processes so that is the
world the world consists of biological
processes that take place in health and
Health Care social processes uh
technology the use of technology and
those who work in data science and
informatics observe measure collect data
these are sometimes described as the
afferent processes so going from the
world
to generating knowledge and so we use
this data to generate knowledge and
that's where a lot of the data science
comes in although people from
informatics do this kind of work too
we've been doing it for many years but
things like um algorithms machine
learning statistics
domain knowledge visualization Etc
once we have this knowledge the data
science Piece of It kind of
Fades away or becomes less prominent and
this is the the world of really pure
informatics because it's it's one thing
to have knowledge but it's another thing
to apply it back to the real world
um in things like electronic health
records and information retrieval
systems
um and decision AIDS and and research
systems and things like that and there
are important other aspects that are
really outside of of data science but
things like evaluation implementation
science how we Implement complex
processes like healthcare human computer
interaction and workflow we've learned
with electronic health records are very
important so um those um these um Payne
and colleagues describe as efferent's
processes where we go from knowledge
back to the world and of course it's a
cycle because as soon as we introduce
knowledge back to the world
um then this psycho repeats itself
um so um I I think this is a nice kind
of overview of maybe some of the
distinctions although a large amount of
overlap among data science and
informatics
so um what are some of the key
challenges ahead for our field so those
of you who are here for the summer our
students you will be exposed to the
field and hopefully learn about these
issues and
um hopefully some of you will even
decide that this is what you want to do
as a career there are lots of
opportunities for careers in biomedical
and health informatics in Academia
Healthcare Systems industry Etc
um but what are some of the key
challenges that we're looking at as a
field we have to continue to improve the
usability of the systems that we impose
on people systems that are hopefully
doing good things helping clinicians
document their work helping researchers
get access to data but we we need to
make those systems better we can't slow
people down I mean this is actually true
for all Computer Applications not just
those in in health care
and we all know how sometimes
frustrating technology can be there's
certainly a lot of challenges for
integrating
um omix data genomics protein geometrics
the microbiome those sources of data are
very rich they tell us a lot about
people and of course integrating them
into care I think is one of the
forthcoming challenges we want to be
able to learn from data we've certainly
seen this in the pandemic even though
we've also learned in the pandemic that
our Data Systems have been very
imperfect
um but data can teach us a lot it can we
can learn about
causes of disease risk of complications
treatments and things like that but it's
imperative that when we do this we must
protect the privacy and security of the
data and of individuals
and and that we did not misuse the data
um there's there's huge opportunities
although also challenges a lot of the
artificial intelligence that that's
being done is really more at this point
in the laboratory stage so people
develop algorithms that can
classify chest x-rays as good as
Radiologists or read a pathology slide
as good as a pathologist that look at a
image of the skin and diagnose it as
well as a dermatologist
but it's one thing to do that in the lab
it's another thing to figure out how
we're going to actually Implement that
in clinical care and and also some of
the algorithms that look at at um
distribution of resources and things
like that really have potential to
um cause bias to be misused and so it's
very important that um as that that we
take AI out of the laboratory and study
it in the real world and then minimize
any kinds of bias in the data and the
algorithms and and so forth
um
and then finally um achieving the goals
of personalized or Precision medicine
um that that could will hopefully lead
to better care when we can take all
different kinds of data and formulate
very personalized precise treatments for
individuals
so
um uh if you want to learn more I
imagine if you're a summer intern you've
probably found some of these sites but
we um like all academic programs these
days we
have a significant presence online we
have a YouTube channel where we actually
record most of these conferences and
post them there and and you can actually
go look at ones that have taken place in
the past we do have a website which
again is can be accessed from this URL
we also have a Blog for the Department
where we talk about interesting things
that we've done we're also moderately
active on social media we do have a
Twitter account and
um and we do tweet things to it we have
a LinkedIn group we also have a Facebook
group and so those are ways to interact
with us online
um you're more than happy to follow up
with me to ask me any questions you can
email me
um I I do have a website and in a moment
I'm going to post the link to these
slides and um and I mentioned that I had
a Blog and I I'm also active on Twitter
um as an individual as well
so I will stop at this point and stop
sharing my screen
and
um happy to
um
and that that's the um uh link to uh
these slides I'm happy to uh answer any
questions or if anyone has any comments
um about
um
something you've heard feel free to type
into the chat or to unmute yourself and
maybe if you're going to talk as well
you can turn your video on and
um
we can have at it
I see we we mostly have
um uh our um summer interns left the
others took advantage of my uh offer
that they uh could uh not not hear a
repeat of my talk
um
but any any comments questions on
anything
okay well um that's fine if there are
none
um uh Andrea or Lauren are there any
um
uh administrative issues for the uh
summer interns that they should yeah
actually there's just one that just came
up